hello hi I'm Angelica temple as you can
see creative human wife to my college
sweetheart Dave is somewhere in the
middle but of course I can't see mom -
baby girl enoki and chief creative
officer and founding partner at Britton
Co I'm so stoked to be here surrounded
by so many inspiring women I can feel
the positive energy please send it my
way when I was thinking about a moment
in my life that could be formed into a
lesson what struck me is that I actually
have a collection of moments that I
would like to share I didn't have a
watershed coming-of-age moment that
caused my story to change in an instant
it's really this collection that all
have one thing in common one guiding
principle one philosophy that I was
actually not aware of until putting
together this talk and to get you there
I'm gonna take you on a lightning fast
version of my life story specifically as
it relates to creativity
starting with dance recitals living on
an artist commune working for the man
and then eventually helping to build
Britain Co so first my beginnings I was
born in the early 80s in New Jersey -
Asha and Arvind who had emigrated from
Jersey Asha
Arvind anyone all right so lots of lots
of fans of my parents they had
immigrated from India in the 60s and
true to Indian immigrant form they were
overachievers who came to the states to
go to Ivy League colleges my mom had a
PhD in psychology from Cornell my dad an
industrial engineer from Berkeley we
lived in Connecticut they got divorced
they each remarried my dad moved to a
farm outside Pittsburgh were their
miniature donkeys my brother went to
college my mom stepped out and I moved
to Salt Lake City and then eventually
Philadelphia I told you lightning fast
okay so I always knew that I loved
creativity I didn't really know what
that meant when I was five years old I
wrote an autobiography on myself
and declare that I was a professional
artist and author and I quote would use
art to save the world from pollution in
the same autobiography I declare Guns
N'Roses Paradise City the best song of
all time not much has changed I did all
the normal creative kiddo stuff I took
tap and jazz lessons clarinet guitar
piano theater camp in the summer then
when I got older I added soccer and
basketball into the mix when we were 10
moved from Connecticut to Salt Lake City
quite a cultural shift that is where I
spent my most formative years when I was
I had a pretty crazy back surgery
because I had scoliosis and had metal
rods put on either side of my spine from
my neck to my tailbone so dance and
sports out painting drawing creative
writing in let's go all in on this so
then when I was 15 let's move back
across the country to Philadelphia right
when I figured out who I am so going
into junior of high school is actually
the worst time to move a teenager so I
thought about getting really angsty
spending all my time on AOL Instant
Messenger but I didn't I decided to just
do all the things I decided okay I'm in
this super liberal place in comparison
with Salt Lake so I started volunteering
for political campaigns I took art
classes at night I went to yoga in the
morning before school which is insane in
school I was on yearbook I joined all
the different political and art groups I
did a large-scale sculpture series it
was overachieving but in an odd place to
achieve I was also known on the internet
for having the largest collection of
bootleg bootleg Ani DiFranco concerts so
that was another really important claim
to fame anyway high school is done I am
now going to Middlebury a small liberal
arts college in Vermont we have fans of
Vermont so if you've been to Vermont in
the summer or late fall you know that it
is paradise like Adam and Eve level
breathtaking in a very cushy lovely spot
to find yourself so I did the very
practical thing and double majored in
philosophy and studio art
you know I was like I'm gonna do all of
this but it's not gonna make sense so in
addition to that I was the vice
president of my co-ed fraternity I ran
an art club I revived a feminist art
magazine called Artemis I had a radio
show all four years I met the love of my
life who I know is somewhere in the
middle and I found my passion creativity
now for me this thing around creativity
it was not about making things myself it
was actually about helping others and
empowering people to share their work
with the world I thought I would see
friends doodling and be like I need to
frame that and put in an art show or I
need to publish that in my Artemis
magazine people humored me and I figured
that if I empower the creative folks
around me that maybe everyone would
think hey I'm creative too the margins
of my sociology notes look pretty good
so that was my thing i busy bead and I
hustled through and I was very motivated
by the present but of course I had not
thought about the future at all so it's
may of my senior year and I have no idea
what's happening next like not a clue
like so many people at that age I was
totally lost I knew I was passionate
about hanging out with my friends
organizing art shows I was still into
Ani DiFranco at the time I still am and
Guns N'Roses
anyway I digress but I really didn't
know what it meant to be creative like
what is that as a profession do i intern
at a gallery a museum what do I work at
an ad agency like I really had no idea
what was next and liberal arts schools
don't have design and communications
degrees it was just studio art and
philosophy so um a photographer friend
of mine who had graduated the year
before was living in an artist colony in
northern Vermont she invited me to an
exhibition there and I drove two hours
north to the tiny town of Johnson a
hamlet of creativity nestled in a part
of Vermont legitimately called the
Northeast Kingdom I parked my Subaru
obviously walked onto campus
and honestly it is impossible to
articulate what it's like to find your
place when you're completely lost
everywhere I looked artists were
flitting about poets writers sculptors
painters from all walks of life all ages
from all around the world all United to
do one thing make art it was like summer
camp for adults all year-round and they
were grownups and it made sense but it
didn't I couldn't believe it was real so
I met the founder and he offered me a
role as a staff artist in residence in
exchange for 20 hours of office work I
would get a studio room and board an
exhibition space okay so I can be an
artist now isn't that an eventually
thing like is that real I told him I
have huge plans and I'm moving to New
York and I need to think about it even
though obviously I had none of those
plans he paused me and he said I mean
what are these big plans what are you
waiting for what do you need to figure
out you can be an artist now you can
just start and that struck me I had
never heard someone say something like
that and I realized I didn't need
permission to do this crazy thing that
was on no path that I knew about I could
actually just do it so I graduated and I
moved to Johnson middle of nowhere I
lived in a cottage with three other
artists every month 50 new artists would
roll in and another thing struck me
these people are using their precious
time to just work on art some people
were funded by nonprofits some people
paid to be there but they were all
taking time out of their daily life most
people weren't what you call full-time
artists it was the first time I'd even
seen something called a side hustle I
don't think that was a term then and it
was really inspiring to me that you
could work and do it little by little
and it didn't it wasn't an eventually
thing so I thought artists colonies are
now my thing so my husband was but my
then boyfriend now husband was about to
graduate and wanted to go to New Zealand
and work on organic farms obviously I
was not I was down with New Zealand not
down to just follow a dude and watch him
pick cherries so I got online
I mean cherries are cool I got online I
applied and got a fellowship to be an
artist in residence in a studio in New
Zealand it was in the middle of nowhere
we lived on a farm next to an animal
refuge and it was a strange time it was
gorgeous and then we wanted to move on
so we wanted to make a year of the
wandering so we decided to go to India
I'd wanted to spend time there besides
just vacations and visiting family so
again I got on the internet I applied
and got a grant to be an
artist-in-residence at an artist
community called the global arts village
outside of Delhi the village was
interesting the people were off it was
actually to be honest it's a way longer
than 10 minutes story and I am like
already gonna be over my time so suffice
it to say it was a front for a cult
a frog died in my room and I escaped in
the middle of the night okay so six
months later we moved to New York I
applied two jobs on monster.com that had
that word creative in them I got a job
as a creative assistant at an ad agency
I decided to work for the man but being
in the corporate world did have its
perks I got an education stipend to take
classes all the time so for the whole
three years I was there I took classes
at night I took silkscreen I took
letterpress clothing construction
anything I could do to hone my craft I
ended up with my first raise I bought a
laptop to build a website and like the
Adobe Creative Suite with mine x-rays I
got a studio space in Greenpoint and I
was working on my printmaking business
then three years in 2009 recession lay
it off okay now I guess I'm an
artist so I did all the normal things I
threw events I design wedding
invitations ice cream printed posters
and t-shirts and sold them at art fairs
I worked at an art startup I was I was
honestly completely lost but I was very
fulfilled I was I did not have very much
money but it was fine and then my
husband and I decided all right we're
done with New York it's over we need to
be outside so we quit our jobs drove
across the country to San Francisco and
the first week
I was here a friend of mine wanted to
introduce me to this gal she knew I
would love Britt so I had taken a random
job at another startup and six months
after that meeting the same gal called
me up said I'd love to talk to you about
a project obviously I gave my two weeks
notice and signed on to be Britt's
founding partner and creative director
and set to work building a company whose
entire mission is to empower women
through creativity so yeah um the lesson
say yes and just start find a way to
jump into the things you love even if
it's not exactly the way you pictured
take a risk with a game plan in mind if
you want to be a professional artist
take art classes at night submit pieces
to a group exhibition enter an art
contest don't wait don't wait until
eventually don't wait for something
magical to happen and finally you can
quit your job and be this dream thing do
it little by little take your time hone
in on your craft then all of a sudden
you might look in the mirror and realize
oh I'm an artist I'm an
entrepreneur and I'm a writer it's
freakin happening and it's amazing thank
you
[Applause]